Sebastian Lege zeigt wie die Industrie
bei Doppelkeksen trickst und lüftet das
Geheimnis, warum das eigentlich keine
Schokoladenkekse mehr sind.
Doppelkekse kennen viele von uns schon seit ihrer
Kindheit, aber auch wenn die Füllung nach
Schokolade schmeckt, drin steckt keine.
Denn laut Lebensmittelgesetz muss
Schokolade auf jeden Fall zwei Stoffe
enthalten, die aus Kakaobohnen gewonnen
werden: Kakaopulver und Kakaobutter.
Während Kakaopulver billig ist, zählt die
Kakaobutter zu den teuersten Fetten der
Welt.
Am liebsten würde die Industrie deshalb
die Kakaobutter komplett durch andere
Fette ersetzen.
Das aber verhindert die Kakaoverordnung,
die fordert mindestens 18% Kakaobutter
und 14% Kakao-Trockenmasse für
alles, was sich Schokolade nennt.
Doch wie ist das bei Schokocremes, zum
Beispiel im Doppelkeks?
Für unseren Schokokeks brauchen wir
eine richtig cremige Füllung, der
Hauptbestandteil ist Fett. Wie die
Industrie nutzt Sebastian dafür
geschmolzenes Palmfett. Das macht rund 50% seiner Cremefüllung aus und
kostet nur ein Viertel von Kakaobutter.
So, jetzt muss es noch richtig schön süß werden. Ordentlich Zucker - wir lieben es doch süß!
Zucker ist nicht nur günstig, er wirkt
auch als Geschmacksverstärker.
Das ist auch nötig, denn an der
aromatischen Hauptzutat wird kräftig
gespart.
Jetzt kommt der Hauptakteur ins Spiel, aber
nicht zu viel -  Kakao ist teuer!
Nur 5% Kakaopulver landen in
der Schüssel,
tatsächlich reicht das bereits aus, um
einen schokoladigen Geschmack zu
erzeugen.
Schokocreme Marke: Billigheimer. Ganz nach Leges Gusto.
Den Schmelz haben wir, die Farbe ist auch da.
Im Kühlschrank wird die Creme
schnell hart, doch kann sie auch mit
echter Schokolade mithalten?
Dazu haben wir sie in eine mundgerechte
Täfelchenform gebracht und bieten sie
Marktbesuchern zur Verkostung an.
Bemerken die Tester den Schwindel?
Schmeckt ein bisschen gemischt wie Vollmilch und Zartbitter, so ein bisschen.
Geröstete Kakaobohnen oder sowas?
Ja, ein bisschen nach Marzipan.
Ganz leicht und sanft. Pralinenartig, schmeckt sehr gut.
Keinem unserer Tester fällt auf, dass es
sich hier gar nicht um Schokolade
handelt. Manche vermuten sogar eine
Spezialität.
Jetzt mal ehrlich, ich würde sie kaufen. Sie zergeht so auf der Zunge. Die ist wirklich lecker.
Aber ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass es eine Schokolade ist, die ich im Supermarkt bekomme.
Die würde ich eher in einem Spezialgeschäft für
Schokolade finden.
Warum nur fallen die Testpersonen so
leicht auf eine billige Schokoladen-Nachahmung herein?
Ein Teil der Antwort liegt im
verwendeten Fett,
denn eine Eigenschaft von Kakaobutter
hat auch das günstige Palmfett. Sebastian
zeigt, welche das ist. Dazu füllt er zwei
Bottiche mit Wasser und erwärmt sie
vorsichtig auf menschliche Körpertemperatur. Kakaobutter, Palmfett. Wie das
schmilzt bei 37 Grad, das sehen wir jetzt hier. Auch in unserem Mund herrschen
knapp 37 Grad.
Und so entsteht dieses unvergleichliche
Gefühl: Das Fett schmilzt auf der Zunge,
kühlt dabei ein klein wenig und setzt
gleich darauf fettlösliche Aromen frei.
Mit einem Wort: Schmelz. Das Experiment
zeigt, in Sachen Schmelz steht Palmfett
der Kakaobutter in nichts nach.
Für das Mundgefühl von Schokolade reicht
das, nur darf so ein Produkt laut Kakao-
Verordnung nicht "Schokolade" heißen.
Doch "Schoko", "Choc" oder "Choco" ist nicht
verboten.
Der Schoko-Begriff ist gesetzlich nicht
definiert. Das heißt, wir haben hier keine
Vorgaben - muss Schokolade enthalten sein
oder nicht. Das gilt nur für das Wort
"Schokolade".
Findige Hersteller nutzen das aus. Für
Verbraucher klingen "Schoko" oder "Choc"
durchaus nach Schokolade,
erlaubt ist die Spitzfindigkeit bei
vielen Produkten, zum Beispiel bei Schoko-
Brotaufstrich. Etikett und Name verheißen
Schokolade, drin ist Palmfett und ein
Hauch Kakao.
Das gilt auch für den Schokoüberzug auf
Fertigkuchen, er besteht statt aus
Schokolade nur aus kakaohaltiger Fettglasur.
Doch nicht alles was "Schoko", "Choc" oder
so ähnlich heißt, ist automatisch
minderwertig. Einige Produkte mit solchen
Kürzelnamen enthalten durchaus echte
Schokolade.
Doch nicht immer steht das Wort
Schokolade auch explizit auf der Packung
oder in der Zutatenliste. Nur Insider
finden sich da noch zurecht.
Der Schoko-Trick ist natürlich für
Verbraucher absolut verwirrend, hier
könnte natürlich der Gesetzgeber ran
gehen und sagen, wo "Schoko", "Choc" oder
etwas ähnliches drauf steht, muss auch
Schokolade enthalten sein. Im Moment
hilft dem Verbraucher nur die
Zutatenliste.
Sieht doch richtig gut aus!
Der Schoko-Trick, ein ärgerliches Verwirr-Spiel mit Worten und Zutaten.
Was riecht das schön nach Schokolade. Auch
Sebastian könnte seine Schokokekse ohne
echte Schokolade so verkaufen. So ein
Schokotraum kann richtig günstig sein
mit ordentlich viel Palmfett.
Worauf achtet ihr beim Kauf von Schoko-
Produkten? Sagt es uns in den Kommentaren!
Und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer Essen
wissen wollt, dann abonniert die ZDFbesseresser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei Clips.